at first glance visitors may not realize
that inside this mosque is a
multicolored secret
[Music]
located in iran the nazir al-mukh mosque
is commonly known as the pink mosque due
to the rose-colored tiles that cover the
interior however this is far from the
only color found inside
a wall of stained glass windows turns
the interior into a rainbow wonderland
[Music]
built in 1888 the mosque took 12 years
to complete
nasir almaq features plenty of
traditional islamic architecture
elements such as the arches and the
central structure however the presence
of stained glass windows a design
element relatively rare for mosques
makes this particular mosque a unique
and stunning sight to see
the stained glass in nasiromoc was built
to catch the morning sunlight as it
reflects off the walls and the brightly
colored persian rugs on the floor
[Music]
the hope and intention was for the
colors to create a peaceful atmosphere
during early morning prayer
[Music]
the nasir almaq mosque has become as
much of a destination for visitors
seeking the perfect photo as those who
still worship under the rainbow of light
[Music]